- And action.
[laughs]
- Why are you not in the car?
- This young man wants
to be an actor too.
Anyway, I'll never forget
what Geena Davis said to me
on the set of "Stuart Little."
"Either you go or I go."
- Lorraine. I will give you
$100 if you go sit in the car.
- Whoa. That's ten times more
than what I got paid
to come here.
- You did this for $10?
- Well, $5 after taxes.
$4 after my agent.
$3 after my manager.
So $3. $3.
♪ ♪
- You should go to law school.
- You know, I think I could
actually live here.
- Whoa. This is moving
a little fast.
- Oh. No, I didn't mean, um,
here here, I just meant--
- Dude.
Chill.
- [laughs]
Okay.
- Uh, it's teachers.
- You bitches!
- Oh, no.
- How? How could you
do this to me?
- Elijah, go back
to the dance, please.
- Stay out of this, Jeremy.
Haven't you done enough
for one night?
- Again, you need to call me
"Mr. Delongpre."
- And you...
I told you my dreams.
We danced together.
Did that mean nothing to you?
- I don't know
how to answer that.
- Typical.
Good-bye, Cary Dubek.
But just tell me one more thing
before I go.
Was that really 911
on the phone for you?
- No.
- [breathy] Wow.
[hip-hop music playing]
- What up, what up?
It's the moment we've
all been waiting for.
He's got hundreds of millions
of views on YouTube
and tonight
he's performing live
with a song that made him
famous.
Give it up for ChaseDreams!
[cheers and applause]
[pulsing electronic
music playing]
- Sorry again he's lip-syncing.
- That's okay.
Did the DJ have the right track
for him to sing to?
- I'm assuming so.
Streeter said
he was taking care
of the singing.
♪ ♪
Oh, no.
I am so sorry for
what's about to happen.
- [off-key]
♪ Girl, since the age of ten ♪
♪ I knew that I would spend ♪
♪ My whole life with you ♪
♪ 'Cause, girl,
you're the cutest girl ♪
♪ In the entire world ♪
- Excuse me.
- ♪ I would die for you ♪
♪ 'Cause when we are together ♪
♪ I can play forever ♪
Hey, Brooke.
[mumbling lyrics]
♪ My friends think I'm crazy ♪
♪ But I'm thinking maybe ♪
♪ I wanna marry you at recess,
uh-huh ♪
♪ Girl, I wanna fight for you,
I wanna cry for you ♪
♪ I wanna-- ♪
[mumbles rapidly]
♪ And together chase dreams! ♪
[music stops]
[light applause]
Okay, that's it.
Thank you so much.
You guys have been so great.
I'm so happy to be here.
But I have to go.
I'm gonna meet Lil Wayne.
Can you believe it?
Lil Wayne! [laughs]
Okay, well, I am so lucky.
Thank you.
Goodnight.
[feedback screech]
[dance music plays]
How do you think that went?
- You told me you were gonna
have him lip-sync.
- We did.
- I thought you meant
to like a track.
- But we promised a live
performance.
- What?
- Hey, Brooke,
we're leaving now?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're done.
You can go sit in the car.
And don't talk.
- But I wanna dance.
These kids are fun.
- Oh, I'm sorry, bud.
But, you know, you'll have
plenty of dances to go to
when you get to high school.
- I'm not going to high school.
I already graduated
on Streeter's phone.
- Yeah.
- Oh, no, that was--
That was just the eighth grade.
- No.
He went through
the whole high school too.
I mean, this guy tore
through the app.
He's a smart little dude.
Ah! [laughs]
Hey, why don't you go say
good-bye to your date,
and then we'll meet
[as Lil Wayne] Lil Wayne!
- No. No.
He's not going to that.
He's staying here.
- Oh. No can do, chica.
I mean, I burned a lot
of bridges to get that invite.
So it'd be poor form
if he didn't show up.
- Well, he's not gonna show,
so why don't you do your job
for the first time tonight
and figure it the [bleep] out.
- Whoa. Who's that?
- That's my sister.
- Yeah, dur.
I meant the guy in all white
with the Kangol.
- Oh, that's nobody.
- Okay, boss, I, uh, hear you.
I admit I had
a few missteps tonight.
But I think there's one thing
that we can agree
that I did not mess up
and that's Lorraine.
Her entrance was perfect,
and she's been sitting out
in the car all night just like
we asked her too.
So [snaps fingers]
here's what we're gonna do.
We're gonna have Lorraine
come to the tequila party,
put on sunglasses and a hoodie,
and Lil Wayne will never
notice, and then Chase
can have his night off.
- Streeter, that's...
That's an amazing idea.
I'm sorry I yelled at you.
You really--you saved
the night.
Thank you.
- No.
And I promise I will...
I will not mess up again.
Okay? [laughs]
Okay.
Take the night off.
Uh-oh! Somebody's
hooking up tonight!
♪ ♪
- You really think
that's gonna work?
- No, she's a
50-something-year-old woman.
But this will buy us
a few hours.
[car door opens]
- [laughs]
Whoo!
Driver take us to Lil Wayne.
[laughs, sighs]
God, it's uncanny.